I am a doctor I'm a doctor I'm a doctor
I'm a doctor I'm a medical doctor not
only am i a medical doctor I went
through a pediatric internship and
residency I ran the pediatric emergency
room at Michael Reese welcome to the D
show I'm Eddie our host and we got an
exciting topic we're going to be talking
about and we're bringing out not just
anybody but an expert in the field and
we're going to let you decide at the end
we're going to take Jimmy Kimmel's
advice you probably aren't going to take
medical advice from talk-show host and I
don't expect you to I wouldn't either or
Robert DeNiro's advice let's find out
the truth let's just find out the truth
to open up the conversation so that
there's more to this than than meets the
eye believe in because chronic disease
and so many other health disorders are
just skyrocketing and no matter what
noble cause you're a part of if your
health goes bad that's it it gets shut
down
so we need to take the matter serious
and we want to make an educated decision
in whatever we do that's just common
sense and we write back with an expert
to cover this very important topic that
has to do with our helps our children's
health don't go anywhere we'll be right
back this is the
this is the thing you know this is the
days of the engine you know this is the
things you welcome back to the DS show
dr. Tony how are you I'm great
how are you thank you for joining us
we're gonna get right into we have a lot
of ground to cover short amount of time
we're going to go to this clip and come
back and take it from there how's that
great let's do it
sizable group of people who are choosing
not to vaccinate their children here in
LA there are schools in which 20% of the
students aren't vaccinated because
parents here are more scared of gluten
than they are of smallpox measles about
now dr. Tony um tell me this is very
interesting Jimmy camo talks about you
know people about being more scared some
people more scared of gluten than they
heart okay I mean it's predictable uh no
it's not you're good a little bit yeah
well I don't I'm actually in ketosis cuz
I'm an athlete and I'm a fat burner but
that's a whole other issue you know and
then he mentioned because of that we
have measles okay and it's totally
unrelated right so there was not one
case of measles during the Disney scare
that was due to an unvaccinated child
spreading it at school I mean so that
was a ridiculous statement and it was
inflammatory and he clearly knows
nothing about what's really going on so
that you know every year we have
hundreds of measles cases in this
country that's normal some years we've
had thousands of measles cases and the
majority of those patients are those
people have been vaccinated measles is a
live viral vaccine which means one of
the side effects could be measles just
like the shingles vaccine one of the
side effects is shingles
it's another live viral vaccine so you
know last year the only two cases of
measles I saw were in kids two teen
girls who were vaccinated to get their
citizenship because in order to come
into this country and to be a citizen
when you get sworn in or where you get
your green card you actually during that
process they check your vaccine record
and you're forced to get whatever
depending on your a
and everyone has to get a flu shot for
that year which makes of course no sense
and so the only measles cases I saw last
year or though it was the year before
during the Disney scare what were two
girls who had just gotten a measles shot
so you know even Gregory Poland who is
the vaccinologist for the u.s. who works
at Mayo Clinic has made it very clear
that you can't eradicate measles with a
lie viral vaccine and that the majority
of people during measles outbreaks and
measles outbreaks in general and failure
will be people who've been vaccinated
that it is a it's called the paradox
it's a paradox of vaccination
specifically around live viral
vaccinations so he knows nothing Jimmy
Kimmel understood nothing and probably
was told by a sponsor or by one of his
producers that he had to get something
in there or he's just so ignorant that
he felt he needed to say something about
it because he really felt passionate and
outraged about something he didn't
understand
and so smallpox by the way was never
eradicated by the vaccine and in fact
the leister method which was came out of
leister england was the method of
stopping VAX mass vaccination because
that was spreading the virus people
assumed it was it actually was the cause
of you know people stopping the
mortality rates for measles but from
smallpox excuse me but it wasn't and
there is you know medical historians one
even from our own town from university
of illinois whose whole thesis is on
smallpox and how the eradication had
nothing to do with vaccination it was
with stopping the vaccine because it was
spreading and so people don't even
understand that there's a lot of
misinformation and rewriting of history
to benefit the pharmaceutical industry
and the health care and that's what
we're here for I truly I want to make an
educated decision like many intelligent
people do Jimmy has some more to say can
we go to mr. you probably aren't good to
take medical advice from talk-show host
and I don't expect you to I wouldn't
either but I would expect you to take
medical advice from almost every doctor
in the world see the thing about doctors
is they didn't learn about the human
body from their friends Facebook page
that I serve your doctor Tony tell us a
little bit I didn't jump into it so
doctors learn nothing about vaccine yes
but you really
you're I'm a doctor I'm a medical doctor
not only am i a medical doctor I went
through a pediatric internship and
residency I ran the pediatric emergency
room at Michael Reese here in Chicago it
was London I ran it I was the director
up what and can I tell you I had never
heard of the vaccine Court I didn't know
about the vaccine compensation program I
didn't know what the table of injuries
was I was told actually I was told at
the time in the 80s we were told to be
careful with vaccines we didn't have as
many anywhere we have probably three or
four times more now for kids up to the
age of 6 or 18 than we did then but we
didn't vaccinate day 1 of life then this
was still not me this was before the Hep
B shot we didn't give preemies vaccines
we waited till we age-adjusted them to 2
months a full term I mean there were so
many things we did differently and
suddenly all that's fallen by the
wayside without any research so doctors
know nothing and I deal in court cases
all the time on vaccine custody issues
where the other side who's supposed to
be an expert actually doesn't know what
the table of injuries is doesn't
wouldn't know a vaccine injury if it
looked them in the eye doesn't know how
vaccines are made doesn't know how
they're approved doesn't know what a
passages doesn't know what a vero cell
is and it becomes very clear to the
judge that actually the only expert in
the room's me and I don't want to sound
like haughty saying that but the truth
is they're brought in as the expert on
the other side and they actually know
nothing about vaccines before I go to
the next clip and this is this this was
the dilemma with a lot of people we were
seeing that when they were asking and
that's why we don't have a truck driver
here we have a medical professional a
doctor Jimmy Kimmel is saying get the
doctors tolerate a doctor so that's why
we have a doctor here many doctors is
very sensitive when you bring this up
they some of them even have stormed out
of the room they're like you don't trust
me you know they don't want to hug it's
like seems like the dot that the
conversation has been shut down if
you're scientists let's see let's hear
that everybody doesn't seem to want to
hear much about it it's shut down oh
they don't want it because it's a belief
system okay it's a belief system it's a
religion not to knock religion but
religion has its place but in belief
systems have their place but not in not
in deciding people's health issues right
so you can't force a product that's
deemed
vojta bleah unsafe that has the
manufacturer zero liability the doctors
get their information really they just
get information and it's just party
towing the party line vaccines are safe
and effective they don't cause injury
you know doctors know nothing about how
they're legally classified how they're
May they don't know the ingredients guys
in learn taxis in medical school not
just that we learnt what we learned
nothing we learned the schedule the
schedule was scheduled when to give them
what date so on your border would be
like you know what date you do this I
mean which has change of course you know
it changes all this ride iddin know that
millions of people don't know that you
that's we don't study vaccines we don't
study innate immunity what you think you
learn about that you know everything
about it for you're injecting something
in some yeah but but but Susan if you
had asked me when I was giving vaccines
in the pediatric clinic what they what
was the ingredient other than the viral
particle I would have said I don't know
I don't know you know thimerosal and a
vital viral particle I mean I didn't
know anything else about it I mean I
admit that I didn't it was like here
this is what you do you work in the
clinic today for 12 hours and you're
giving shots to the everybody's coming
in the clinic is it safe to say we're
saying that what is it what doctors
learn is is what is the information
given to them by the pharmaceutical
company well considering that most
medical schools now get the majority of
funding probably every research chair
gets their funding from Pharma then yes
it's safe to say that and I think that
they start inundating kids young even
with like taking that you know the a CT
or the SAT there's questions about I
know there's questions about GMOs even
at this point so I think that big
industry has had a lot of say in
legislation and policy we're going to
take a break dr. Tony again you've
you've done all of the medical training
you are actually the habit of the what
was I was director of the pediatric
emergency room at Michael Reese and that
hospital no longer exists but it was a
very big Hospital in the heyday and when
I was running it as well we're with an
expert we really want to sincerely get
to the bottom of this open up the
discussion and protect ourselves our
children is a very important topic and
we're with an expert we'll be right back
to talk more on this it's like when did
you think that you had no purpose are
you worthless the value comes from
purpose your purpose in life is to
worship the Creator not worship your
desires himself not worship social
pressure the celebrity culture but
worship the thing that's much higher and
transcendent above and beyond by
worshipping God and seeking his pleasure
you get pleased so you have double
pleasure come back to the Deen show
we're here with the doctor and expert
can we hear some more from Jimmy yes by
the way only this would all be okay if
your kids were the only ones affected
they're your kids but they're not
because unvaccinated kids put all
children in danger especially babies who
are too young to get the vaccination job
but of course that's according to
doctors so dr. Tony is that true that
unvaccinated kids put everyone else in
danger Wow
if that was really the case if all these
healthy unvaccinated kids walk around
seemingly healthy no fever no rash no
coughing but they're spreading disease
to all the vaccinated kids maybe we have
a backwards you know I mean think about
it so if you're sick and you have fever
and you're coughing and you're sneezing
you don't go to school you don't go to
work but the implication is that
unvaccinated kids walk around as petri
dishes and just spread diseases to kids
who've been vaccinated which implies if
you think about it that they have this
healthy immune system and they somehow
carry diseases but they don't themselves
don't get sick and that it's the
vaccinated kids who get sick and their
vaccines fail because of the
unvaccinated kids I mean it really makes
little to no sense whatsoever
and what's really backwards is that what
puts infants at risk is that their
mothers have been vaccinated and don't
have real immunity to give their
children either infants you know either
in utero when they're still baking in
the oven or through breast milk we've
got the we've got pharmaceutical
companies now telling women that they
should delay breastfeeding because it
interferes with response to vaccination
so you know it always was you'd get me
fools who'd get mumps I got all these
diseases you know and so my son was
protected he came out of the womb and he
had a year and a half of antibodies I
breastfed him for four years you could
argue that was long but you know he
argued it wasn't long enough that's why
I stopped but the point is that you know
it's really that we're vaccinating kid
vaccinating people who then go on to
have children who don't have real
immunity they don't impart immunity for
the length of time they should
and now infants are at risk and the
vaccines that they're recommending to
pregnant women and families of people
who are just having babies is the DPT
for the diphtheria and pertussis
specifically but the reality of that
vaccine is that it doesn't prevent you
from being colonized with the bacteria
that's for bacteria
those three bacterias it actually
doesn't prevent you from spreading
disease from being colonized in fact it
increases your risk of colonization of
para pertussis it only protects you
because you get some immunity to the
toxin of those bacterium but in reality
you are more likely to be colonized with
para pertussis and then spread it to
your newborn who did not get protection
from you because you never in real
immunity so he has no idea what he's
talking about but it's great industry
speak that he's picking up and somebody
gave it to him to spew and he's spewing
it but it's not real it's not factual
it seems like Robert De Niro he spoke on
the matter he's very concerned but there
is something there there's something
there that people aren't addressing and
for me to get so upset here today on the
Today Show you guys means that's
something there that's all I wanted was
the movie to be seen people can make
their own judgement but you must see it
and other there are other films other
things that also just document and show
you know it's not such a simple thing
and that caused many other people to be
very concerned and if you're concerned I
mean you don't want to blindly jump into
something you know God gave us this
brain we have it use it to investigate
look at it and talk to experts that's
what we have an expert on the show and I
really sincerely want to get to the
bottom of this there's there's some more
we're going to go to another clip and
get your feedback on it okay from Jimmy
so I think it should go if you
or one of those people who knows more
than doctors that's fine no vaccinations
but you're not allowed to go to the
doctor anymore if you fall and you cut
your head open you will not be admitted
to the emergency room okay dr. Tony are
you I mean if we had somebody here was
are you anti doctor I am NOT anti doctor
I mean he talks about now stitching up
yourself
you know even though I mean we do see I
mean I I've interviewed some of the some
people who are very health conscious
people take care of themselves you know
eat real food they avoid fake food they
avoid many of these GMOs and and and the
facts you know they speak for themselves
I think that the third leading cause of
death is medical errors over 140,000 and
I think it's much it's not medical
errors it's medical treatment it will
treat medical treatment and I think it's
the first leading cause of death by the
way not even the third when you're a
doctor tell mister but I mean obviously
so where's the balance here when do you
I mean you heard what he said what are
your comments on well from an ethics
standpoint he's totally off and you know
his whole concept is unethical you
cannot deny people emergency room visits
you can't deny people trauma care I mean
that's ridiculous really you know and
you're going to deny a child trauma care
because the mother decided not to
vaccinate and you have a feeling about
whether that was right or wrong
I mean he's you know I can't I'm not
going to swear on your show but you know
if I could I'd be screaming right now I
mean it's really ridiculous he also acts
as though people decide not to vaccinate
on a whim the majority of parents in the
movement for vaccine awareness by the
way is our parents who's lost a child
secondary to vaccination or whose
child's life was damaged secondary to
vaccination and many of those and many
of those cases have been proven and many
of those cases are obvious so a lot of
them couldn't even be proven because we
have such a short statute of limitations
in order to file a complaint against the
government because you can't sue the
company so it's you know the whole
system is set up against against people
its episodes of the 1986 someone 1986
law made it impossible to sue directly
you cannot nope you have to sue that
Department of Health and Human Services
and the the you have to sue part of the
federal government and you only have
three years to final get like that kind
of gives you know a lot
a lot of shield of liability keine yeah
how about a few you know you buy a car
seat for the kid and now their head
explodes on impact you get to sue the
car company I mean you get along what if
what if you didn't right well yeah and
what if you were forced to buy the same
car seat that's damaged over and over
again yeah let's go to another clip and
get your feedback okay
you should also let your kids smoke why
wouldn't you the only people who say not
to our doctors and they don't know oh
that's so interesting considering that
the doctors were the last vestige of
professionals and public people who came
forward they always said that smoking
was good for you and they recommended
Camel cigarettes I mean the AMA got
behind the whole tobacco science thing
so what a great example doctors were the
one saying smoking was safe and
beneficial and camels were the bed--the
all doctors choose camels I mean you had
the whole AMA behind that campaign so I
mean it's such a ridiculous topsy-turvy
example he's giving dude doctors some
doctor I mean there there are great
doctors out there yourself one of them
many who are out there really serving
humanity who would put their lives on
the line many you know and but are there
if you gave this wonderful example about
the nicotine industry where I mean we
know now you know many you were saying
who are smoking themselves they were
they were being paid they were being
paid I mean the whole AMA the whole
system was being paid the horses to
profit to market help the tobacco
industry market their products through
tobacco science they were holding on
tooth and nail until the very end you
know that until like what 75 76 until
the very end when we when the data was
there for years and years and years this
isn't any difference we're gonna take a
break are you willing tomorrow if we get
again we want to just get to the bottom
of this we want what's best for
everybody I mean want to get educated
Robert De Niro because there are many
people who will come out and say no I
saw my kid change like overnight I saw
what happened and I should have done
something and I didn't so that there's
more to this than than meets the eye you
know he had some his son my child is
autistic and every kid is different but
there is something
there there's something there that
people aren't addressing who was who was
affected and that caused him to educate
himself and he said there's something
here there's something going let's open
up the discussion let's talk about it if
a doctor was what content from Chicago
or anywhere else and they wanted to sit
and talk on the show absolutely it down
to dialogue about urine mm baby okay
we're going to take a break we'll be
right back with more here with dr. Tony
know anyway take that simple step that
you asked your maker to guide you that
he'll guide you yes
I advise this a lot for people
researching put your head on the floor
and in the in the state of profession
like all the prophets did and ask the
creator of the universe to show you the
way to guide you to the straight path
and someone who sincerely us so guided
it's upon a little foundation your son
that's it back here on the Dean show
we're trying to get to the bottom of
this there are I I've seen you know
investigating you know trying to dig out
the truth you see that there's hundreds
of doctors like yourself you're not one
you know just thousands extra thousand
yeah but they don't seem to have the
platform the mic you know to be able to
they would lose their jobs
Wow they would lose their jobs let's go
to the next clip yeah I am a doctor I'm
a doctor I'm a doctor I'm a doctor and I
believe in vaccinations good for you I
did do you did - I did - yeah I didn't
question them what what what what did
they no different than you'd are they on
to some that you've missed out on I
don't think so I mean I pushed
vaccinations I was pissed if parents
came in the ER and they weren't up today
but it was there was nothing substantial
behind it I didn't know it it's it
you're inculcated from day one to
believe it it's a belief system what
made you take a turn then so Iran took
yeah yeah yeah yeah I got the cool kid
anymore you know at our tea
you know John I'm infamous eatable right
no one wants me infamous
um okay well so it was a very long it
was a process actually and the process
went like this you know we were told
like I was told when I had chicken pox
at age 26 because I somehow didn't get
it until I was exposed to other kids
with chicken pox I'm the youngest and my
family and I missed out in it so I was
told by the head of my department you
know we'll have to give the kids you
exposed in the oncology department the
chickenpox vaccine but well it would
never be mandated vaccine because all
vaccines come with a real risk of
encephalitis and death and for
chickenpox it's not worth it the amount
of people who died there's a small
amount of people who die every year out
of hundreds of millions and they're all
on steroids or chemo and half our adults
and they're but you know they would die
from the next virus that came through
and usually was an average about a
hundred a year in the whole country and
he said so we'd never mandated we'd
never recommend it so that was one thing
we you know we never gave pregnant women
shots we never gave women who were
thinking of getting pregnant within a
six-month period time shot so we were
warned in the 80s that vaccines had a
risk that's changed but then when I ran
the ER and when I was a resident um and
an intern I saw kids who were in the
vaccine clinics that morning come back
with seizures and was in with breathe
you know they had stopped breathing
APNIC events so right and if the apnic
event wasn't caught it would have been
SIDS and we had one or two cases over
there several year period that I was in
the ER where it was a SIDS case but with
many cases where they stopped breathing
and within you know a day or 72 hours of
the vaccine clinic and usually it was in
the same day so you know there was an
understanding that some kids react badly
like wow I don't want that to be my kid
and then you know as I I ran the ER I
saw this I then went back a siren
studying other forms of medicine and
realize okay there's a lot of ways to
treat illness and you know I was just
very confident treating kids with
chickenpox and mumps and measles and we
saw this you know we saw this all
through our residency and my time at U
of I in it at NYU and so okay so I know
some kids are going to react badly and
there's other ways of treating kids so
that's one level and then I do
this master's program a few years ago I
went to Haiti after the earthquake and I
do a master's program and disaster
response and everything's about the flu
shot flu shot flu shot let's push flu
shot clinics and I start doing the
research into the flu shot and I was
like oh wow and I went to the head of my
department who's part of DARPA so DARPA
is like a US forces defense team right
he meets monthly at the Elm in DC and I
said you know the actual data on the flu
shot doesn't look pretty good I'm not
sure why we're spending so much money in
time having all these masters programs
in disaster response modeling flu shot
clinics and so he just written a whole
paper and how great flu shot was and how
important it was and when he looked at
the actual independent research like
from Cochrane the Cochrane Collaboration
which takes no money from industry he
was like whoa this is big and so we he
said stay on this vein and keep looking
at this stuff and all I did was like one
vaccine after another looking at the
policy how are the policy set who's on
these committees what are the conflicts
of interest you know how did it get
state-by-state mandate and when I
started looking at all these things and
after the actual independent research I
realize that it's kind of an emperor
with no clothes and that it's really
pushed these all these I had no idea
there were so many new vaccines create I
know that we're on the mandate I hadn't
even heard of half of them because I'd
been out of peds at that point and I
also had no idea that there were these
advisory committees at all had financial
conflicts of interest I mean there's one
thing after another so when I actually
looked at the independent Reap data and
looked at all the conflicts of interests
and then I found out there was something
called the vaccine court and a law
passed in 1986 the year I graduated med
school and never heard about it the
vaccine court yeah so the National
Vaccine Compensation program the
companies don't pay but who pays it so
so when you get a vaccine you pay 75
cents per antigen on that vaccine that
goes into a pool into the federal
government and that is what is used to
pay out and to fight against parents
whose kids have been damaged or died
from the vaccines or not just kids
because it's adults to a flu shots a big
reason that people file a claim in the
vaccine court but the reason the vaccine
court one of the reasons a vexing Court
was created was because in the 70s there
were so many
cases that the pharmaceutical companies
lost specifically with the wholesale DPT
shot with brain damage and death and
autism and that the insurance company
said we're not going to insure the
manufacturers anymore for this specific
for vaccines like will insure you for
your other drugs but we're not going to
assure you so the drug companies wanted
it and then the parents were sick and
tired having spent a lot of money in
tort you know as a tort case and they
thought it would be a no-fault issue so
what happened was there was something
called the table of injuries set up like
for every vaccine that we give here's
the table of known injuries if they
happen in a certain amount of time you
don't have to prove it you just go to
file a claim and you'll get paid out
well that was when they were 14 mandated
shots we now have anywhere from 53 to 69
depending on the state if you also if
they also mandate annual flu shot and
now in some states are pushing for that
HPV in Rhode Island has mandates so they
didn't update the table of injuries
after that first time they made the
court in 1986 and yet we've added all
these more vaccinations like look at
that chart I don't know if you can see
the chart but you know we grew all the
different vaccines and we haven't
changed the table of injuries one iota
which means everyone has to now prove
the injury and it's very hard to get
physicians who are willing to put
themselves in line and you know it's
just it's become impossible so it's it
the whole thing is rigged and I didn't
know this so it was an evolution at
first I just thought well some kids
react badly I don't want to take that
risk with my kids but then I was big
then I went from some kids react badly
to they don't even do what they're
supposed to do and they're not even that
safe so it's worse than I thought but it
was a process I didn't get there
overnight it was over a 20-year period
we were asking do we follow Jimmy Kimmel
and shut down the conversation or do we
look to someone like Robert De Niro who
wants to open it up let's talk about it
before we go to break someone's asking
look I was at Sam's Club and someone
gave me this flyer and I was like hey
you know doctor Tony had before you used
to be I'm coming to see you I see my
other doctor I asked him question he
throw me out the room you know I can't
ask but maybe you'll tell me I got
nineteen sixty two two shots today
almost was
72 they say I put it it's a little
bacteria but it in everything okay right
have a nice day
yeah have a nice day until you come back
with your autoimmune disease so it's not
that easy it's not that easy and it's so
pervasive you know first of all if your
source of income depends upon a paradigm
you don't want to question it because
then you have to like find a new job and
risk you know nobody in a big
institution and any big organization
institution you know you want to belong
if you want to sit right you don't want
people talking about you you don't want
to risk your job and so there's a lot of
pressure to not even look at the issues
right there like I've literally had
other doctors tell me I don't want to
know because if I knew I'd have to
change the way I practice
Wow but but haven't you you you were
part of many documentaries one is bought
and there has been investigators they've
been people who come out who work for
pharmaceutical company Pharmaceuticals
had to pay billions of Doc's was one of
those I left on for like five years they
knew and they knew of course they knew
from the beginning the research suddenly
appeared on like brandy Vaughn like on
her desk other people's desks when the
case came out I mean the the
pharmaceutical industry all the main
vaccine players have been found guilty
all of them have been found guilty of
criminal charges numerous times in
federal courts so not necessarily on
vaccines but around whatever issue right
but so why are we to their criminal
entities these are criminal entities
they're a criminal ring why should we
trust the data they give us they do
their own safety studies they don't use
real placebos they use expects scenes as
the placebo or the aluminum adjuvant or
they use an experimental vaccine that's
never been tested as the placebo I mean
why do people trust the data coming from
these entities because the FDA does
because the CDC does because the
advisory committees are made up of
people who actually sit on who work for
those vaccine companies and then sit on
the advisory boards they have a conflict
of interest we have something called
FACA Federal Advisory Committee Act and
the CDC as a matter of fact gives grants
a waiver of the conflict of interest to
everybody on there
a subcommittee the vaccine committee
there so there's no check-and-balance
at all it's all become political eyes
we're going to take a break lot to
process
let's open up the discussion learn
educate ourselves and then make the
informed decision we'll be right back
with more here today's show
thank you very much for being with us on
this episode of the D show subscribe
right now so you can get the rest of
this interview when it comes out next
week God willing in sha Allah make sure
that you tune in with an open heart and
open mind and then you decide do we
follow Jimmy Kimmel's advice or do we
open up the conversation and take Robert
DeNiro's advice they're not experts in
this field that's why we brought on an
expert to get to the bottom of this into
sincerely earnestly seek out the truth
because if you seek you shall find be
back with us next week until then peace
be with you and salaam like